[Music]
[Music]
what did you do this weekend Diana
nothing very interesting warrior of the
Amazons daughter of Zeus
and protector of the world she grew up
isolated from the world of men to super
smart super sophisticated full of hope
she's the most talented warrior that
time doesn't care for the fame or for
the glory
she partners with Batman to unite the
need asking people we don't know to risk
their lives
I know so this works she's this glue to
the team
she makes each and every one of them
feel stronger and capable
he said the age of heroes who never come
again Bastogne
just the end of the world that baby too
you can't save the world enough they do
this together
all in
[Music]
[Music]
I'll take that as a yes what the ring
[Music]
Superman violence acts of war and
terrorism are all on the rise I had a
dream it was the end of the world
I think it's something more something
darker
we're asking people we'd unknown to risk
their lives strong man and strong alone
never heard that it's not a saying
that's the opposite of what the saying
is
divided we are not enough
[Music]
morley Superman
[Music]
why I brought you together
ride ain't over yet man
[Music]
[Music]
Oh awesome as a bad thing oh that's your
solution sorry it's your signal that
means we have to go now yeah I saw that
man it's so cool
[Music]